yo we are gonna be so rich once we
robbed this lady Zack you are a genius
hey don't call me Zack call me by my
code name I'm sorry
Matterhorn I forgive you Jungle Cruise
yeah what's wrong with you small world
ah I really dislike the name small world
well would you feel better if we called
you Thunder Mountain no no no you guys
it's not the name I just don't
understand why our code names have to be
Disney theme park rides why not dad
everyone likes Disneyland hmm not
everyone I don't like Disneyland Oh what
are you serious yes I mean I just don't
get the appeal what did you even have a
hat yes I have a heart in all honesty
I've never even been to Disneyland so
what okay okay hold on hold on how can
you hate someone you've never even
experienced what excuse me Justin hates
broccoli yet he's never had broccoli
they look like little trees I don't see
how anyone eats them okay yeah but this
is Disneyland
Disneyland's the best sob past what
makes it the best it's beautiful it's
magical time stops when you're there you
don't have a fret in this world is the
food reasonably priced like honestly I
can justify spending $11 on the corndog
cuz it's that good okay listen I've seen
the commercials it's too crowded and I
don't like that okay it gets a little
crowded but when you're there it's like
we're one big happy family
sounds like trash you are a monster hey
lady do you like Disneyland answer the
question
I'll tell you about it see given shoot
like Suzanne one okay so she likes it
people like it I don't like it it's not
for everybody you were crazy hey keep
your voice down okay you're a
professional during the job I'm so sorry
you're right hey both of you just listen
how about tomorrow we take a little trip
down in busy Lana just make a day out of
it okay okay I will try it but if I
don't like it and that's the end of this
how about a group hug huh I'm feeling
group hug
let's go this is nice mm-hmm
I totally forgot we're in the middle of
a robbery just got caught all right guys
Disneyland in three to five years
Disneyland in three to five years